I'd like to say a couple of things if I
if I marry I mean he's received
innumerable awards and distinctions the
Turing award they're all shop prize of
many other things but over and above
that I think we think of the whole field
of logic in computer science it's pretty
hard to imagine it as the thriving field
of research that it is today without
those seminal and fundamental
contributions in particular to the logic
and semantics area is the main theory of
denotational semantics beyond those
technical contributions Dana's connected
the whole field with the great
traditions of mathematical logic which
is also made of course huge
contributions and his vision of the
subject I think has been a source of
wisdom and guidance for all of us over
the years so I think it's very fitting
that he should give the opening lecture
of this bootcamp at a deed of this
program so
Thank You Samson very much and it's
great to be able to greet all of you
here this has been a long time in
planning and so it's wonderful that it's
actually taking place now I must say
that Berkeley is incredibly lucky to
have the Symons Institute and the Symons
Institute is incredibly lucky to have
this building I was on the faculty here
when it was originally built for Calvin
the Nobel Prize winner he wanted a round
building you can read about it - stout
side the door here he wanted a round
building to make sure that collaboration
took place of course who was filled with
laboratories for a long time now the
building is filled with theory but I
hope it makes collaboration I'm a little
bit alarmed by the glass offices up
there I'm thinking I'm going to bring a
lot of a crepe paper to cover the window
so no one can see how much time I
wasting at political news every day
that's why I was waiting here and I
looked on my iPhone at political news
and I want to tell you that Zuckerberg
Mark Zuckerberg has visited the Vatican
and had an audience with the Pope he
wore a tutu suit and tie which was very
good he gave the Pope a drone I don't
know what the Pope is going to do with
that I guess he could bless whole cities
at the same time where they're going
only someone from Silicon Valley would
think of something like that
so want to bring up my slides here
whole screen yeah
one thing I suggested to Prakash this
morning is it might be possible to
establish a Dropbox site for this
semester because there's lots of papers
and things
I mean we're covering very wide number
of subjects there and I think one of the
good outcomes of this could be that you
all go home and teach a new course but
in order to do that you need to have a
lot of background material so I think if
we establish the Dropbox site to put key
papers in and maybe you can put comments
on why you think the papers are
important now that will be a great thing
to be able to use after you go home
after this session many of you have
heard the talking about to give before
but that's okay because what I'm
emphasizing is the basis of it and I'll
explain why I want to emphasize that
let's see if I can use the remote here
there we go I gave this talk at CU and
why in the summer I was hoping to see
Raymond somalian an old old friend but
his health is not too good at the moment
and I used as a theme his puzzle book to
mock a mockingbird where he pretends
that there is this forest of birds that
speak in Combinator's their bird calls
accommodators and then when you combine
the Combinator's together you get other
interesting bird calls and so I made
this terrible joke that maybe the birds
are speaking a kind of pigeon version of
Curry's language there it's not true of
course ramus volume is absolutely formal
and all the things the the rules he uses
they're exactly Curry's rules but he
does advance amusing stories as to what
they're doing so that might be a
teaching aid if you like that sort of
thing
and I also collected some other
quotations one thing appropriate for the
topic I'm emphasizing today is that
Turing wanted to introduce random
elements in it I'm sure he thought in
terms more of a physical device that
would produce random numbers and we use
pseudo-random number generators there
but I'm trying to emphasize today that
there is a theory that you can just call
on ordinary probability theory to
introduce random elements in a way
that's very familiar from other areas of
probability theory
I also remember Alan Perlis the late
Alan Perlis he loved epigrams about
programming they're fun to read you can
find them on the net some of them are a
bit out of date there he didn't like
Turing machines very well and so he had
that sarcastic comment there and he was
very pleased with the pun he made about
me because of course I studied with
Alonzo Church and then for the domain
theory I introduced a lot of lot of
stuff that he thought was much much too
theoretical and so he put that in I
noticed when his department put up their
version of his epigrams they left that
out because they didn't understand the
joke and they thought someone might sue
against them especially the Mormons
might sue against themselves they left
that out
so we can remind ourselves about
churches lambda calculus and here's the
notation standard notation that I'm
using lambda abstraction and then you
have some formula in here within fluid
with a variable there and alpha
conversion means alphabetic converts of
their Curry's name for it means it
doesn't matter which bound variable use
but of course you have to be careful
about free and bound variables and then
for computer science applications there
has been a big development and nominal
logics for other handling of bound
variables to be interesting to discuss
but I'm going to be very informal today
about doing it now the key thing about
I'm the calculus is of course if you
form a lambda abstraction here that's
supposed to be the name of the function
that does whatever you said it was
supposed to be doing then if you apply
that function to an argument you better
get the answer you were supposed to get
out of it and so you assume that
axiomatically again beta conversion is
Curry's name for it and the reason that
it's called bandy conversion is that
beta is a second letter of the Greek
alphabet
there is no metaphysical explanation for
beta for lambda I once asked John
Addison church's son-in-law do you know
why church used lambda for lambda
abstraction he said no I don't all right
- my father-in-law and ask him so you
wrote a postcard
dear professor Church John always
referred to this all in law as professor
Church dear professor Church Russell had
the iota operator and Hilbert had the
epsilon operator why did you choose
lambda for your operator the various
story is floating around about how it
came but church just annotated the
postcard and put in envelope and sent it
back and his complete annotation was any
meaning
miny moe there is no metaphysical
significance to choice of the lemon some
people think it's a circumflex you got
transformed there but I don't believe in
the story I don't use the AVA conversion
here
inna here at course stands for
extensionality and they think of this as
sensuality it's too strong it says
everything is a function everything is a
function that's a little bit stronger
and I don't assume that axiom here now
is the model using enumeration operators
so in order to build up this model you
have the following ingredients you have
the integers and we have a small amount
of Gretel numbering on the integers so
every positive integer is uniquely
factorable into an even part in an odd
part there and so that means every
positive integer can stand for an
ordered pair of the two components there
of course this is a rather wasteful
gradable numbering because it's
exponential and you can give polynomial
once but it doesn't matter for this
discussion here we just have some
griddles numbering for ordered pairs and
then by iterating ordered pairs and this
is even more wasteful here because it'll
be excellent Exponential's Exponential's
you can find girdle numbers for finite
sequences Gretl use prime factorization
but this is a very cheap and quick way
to say oh yes there must be some girdle
numbering for finite sequences and I use
the finite sequences also to number
finite sets now zero these are always
nonzero things
oh it no except for the empty sequence
but the empty sequence or the number
zero can also stand for the empty set
and if you do this console operation
here of course what this stands for is
the set that you have in the first part
here
and one extra element on the end so
those are very simple-minded kinds of
griddle numberings and then I use the
notation of the kwaini star you can
think of X as an alphabet here and so
you ask yourself what are the girdle
numbers of all the finite sequences that
you can form selecting elements from the
set X and so that's the meaning of this
now here is the definition in terms of
enumeration operators and of course if
you have some other girdle number in
there you can use the same kind of
definition there but this girdle
numbering is convened especially it's
important here that the girdle number of
a compound thing is strictly greater
than the girdle numbers of the pieces of
the of the structure there so the idea
of an enumeration operator is you start
a numerating X and then look at all the
finite subsets of X and note their
girdle numbers of the finite subsets and
then you start the numerating f i call f
a lookup table here whenever you match a
finite set to the first component of
something that you found in F that look
finding that as a lookup in F that gives
you leave to output m as one element of
the set that's being enumerated so as
you'll numerate X and as you'll numerate
F these are just sets of integers your
ax numerating what I'm calling here f of
X now you can just turn that definition
around the other way there the opposite
thing is lambda abstraction is if you
have a nice formula that should be
pretty well-behaved and I'll explain
what well behaved means in a minute here
then you stick in finite sets by via
their girdle numbers to get a
corresponding transform set here
according to the formula whatever it is
and then you see what elements you would
get as the value this is set there and
then you put that in the lookup table
here and I'll tell you in a minute
I throw in the number zero which is not
an ordered pair for a simple reason for
nice loss there so why does this model
work as a model for the lambda calculus
so first we'll recall that the power set
of n is the topological space
it's a topological space in two familiar
ways if you think of it as 2 to the N
then you give the product apology there
and you get the counter space the
household space I'm using the weak
topology here of positive information
here where I only use so to speak half
of the counter space topology there you
could think of this as sometimes there
you introduce the sierpinski space which
is a two element space that has one open
point and one closed point if you think
of two as a discrete space both points
are open and closed at the same time but
this your Pinsky space is is weaker and
so the topology that corresponds to that
product topology is to take as a basis
for the open sets those families of sets
because we're thinking of the points of
the space as sets here which have a
certain finite amount of information do
them and so that makes a very nice
topology there I know professor is for
Pinsky I met him several times and
Warsaw at other places it's very sad to
have a two-point space named after you
it seems me
now in terms of this topology it's very
easy to explain continuity here it just
says a finite amount of information
about the arguments to a function a
finite amount of information about the
value of the function is already
determined by a finite amount of
information about the arguments and you
can make that entirely analogous to the
epsilon-delta definition of continuity
over the real numbers there a finite
approximation to the value you get will
remain stable under a finite amount
approximation to the arguments and this
topology is even easier than the real
number topology there because it's easy
to combine continuous functions in a
nice way and now we can see immediately
that as a binary operation this is
continuous because a finite subset of
this is already determined by a finite
subset of X and a finite subset of F and
so we have lots of continuous functions
immediately the binary operation for the
lambda calculus models there also it's
very easy to see from the definition
that if you have a continuous function
of several variables and you apply
lambda abstraction to it then that's the
result is continuous in this because a
finite subset of this will be determined
by a finite subset here and it will be
already determined by a finite number of
information about the arguments of the
other arguments there
and the way I set it up here because I
put into the definition here of taking
all possible ways of checking this out
here and I threw in zero to make sure
that every number has paid attention to
then the meaning of lambda X Phi of X
where Phi as a continuous function is
the largest lookup table that gives you
the right values when you use the binary
operation of there and so you can see
instead of the ADA law this is the
largest lookup table that behaves the
same way that this lookup table does you
can have very succinctly up tables to
give you a function there but the way
lambda is defined in this model this is
the largest table that will give you the
right answers there
and so that so it's very easy to once
you see how the role of continuity here
it's very easy to see that this model
satisfies the church Curry axioms for
lambda calculus now every once a while I
wake up in the middle of the night at
about 4 o'clock and I kick myself in the
butt because when I was a graduate
student in Princeton under church I
could have given this definition and
then I would be rich and famous I don't
care so much about rich
because all of this stuff is very
simple-minded from the point of view of
mathematics and a little bit of logic a
little bit of girdle don't bring a
little bit of topology there and it was
something I could explain then even more
embarrassing is that both my Hill and
Jefferson and Hartley Rogers had thought
of what corresponds to enumeration
operators so my hel interprets and I
knew both of them very well they thought
about defining partial functionals on
partial functions
you remember clay nice big advance was
good will only use total functions but
Clanny realized that said so recursion
needn't complete its effort there it's
much better to use partial functions and
defining recursive function theory and
so why Helen Shepherdson said good let's
think about operators on those
functionals on those and in their paper
they say wow no they didn't exactly say
well but in effect they say look at all
the cool though they didn't say cool
look at all the operators we can define
they defined lambda abstraction for
partial functionals so that you could
get lots of partial functionals on the
other hand with his student Freiberg who
saw the post problem rogers in his
lectures at MIT was trying to explain
degree theory and he thought a Turing
calculation has to use both positive and
negative information about the input for
assessing degrees and so Rogers thought
they're just using positive information
about it would give an easier theory of
degrees and so they introduced the idea
of enumeration operators and it's the
definition I'm given
for f of X is word-for-word practically
what's in Hartley Rodgers book except
for the choice of Journal numbers there
here's a strange thing both of them had
good definitions neither group said well
what's the algebra of these operators I
could have discovered lambda calculus
just from the work that they had done
there but they didn't think in those
terms so that's why I kick myself every
once in a while now here are some easy
properties that you can get then instead
of the ADA rule of extensionality we
have a better kind of extensionality
here it says one lookup table is
contained in another group of table if
and only if point wise the first
function is less than or equal to the
second function and in fact this lambda
abstraction preserves meet and join
Union in the Union in intersection here
it's a lattice theoretic morphism
because the function space is not
exactly the same as the power set the
function space is a retract of the power
set and it has nice lattice theoretic
properties there and it's very easy to
prove a number of them from these
definitions and of course from the point
of view of computability as we can now
give a definition of a computable
continuous operator on the power set of
the integers there because when you
lambda abstract on all the variables so
you make the full lookup table that
gives you the total structure of the
continuous function on all of its
variables if that lookup table is
recursively enumerable then that's a
good idea of a computable operator
and we can do more computations there if
we think of how to get recursive
definitions you can check quite easily
from the definitions that lambda terms
always define computable operators if
utils take pure lambda terms that have
lambda and application as the only
components then they will be computable
but even better you can do a recursion
by getting a fixed point of a continuous
operated it's quite easy gladys
theoretically to show that every
monotone operator has a least fixed
point and every continuous operator has
an even more economical fixed point but
in terms of the model korea's
paradoxical Combinator here by using
self-application gives you a formula in
the lambda calculus for the least fixed
point and it's quite easy to prove that
that is a fixed point of course just
from the rules of lambda calculus but
because I set up the girdle numbering to
be well-founded numbering namely the
girdle number of a finite structure is
always larger than the girdle numbers of
the parts of it that well founding this
allows you to give a proof that this is
in fact the least fixed point operator
and of course it follows that fixed
points of computable operators are also
computable and we can push this a little
bit further here of seeing how
computable things arise by just taking
the arithmetic Combinator's on the power
set here we just promote successor
predecessor and test for zero up one
level here to the sets of integers here
by those obvious definitions and then
lambda calculus together with the
arithmetic convert combinations
give you a notation a functional
programming language
that will give you every computable
continuous function and we can even do
it by setting up girdle numbers for the
combinations here and this is just a
sketch here you can control continuous
functions so that they're really
determined by what they do to
Singleton's and then the continuous
function on a whole set is just the
union of all the values on the
singletons there and it's quite easy to
set this up with lambda calculus
definitions so curie showed us that it
culminated as k NS give you all lambda
definable things so if you combine
curries combinators with arithmetic
Combinator's and just apply them one to
the other over and over again so we can
use girdle numbers here and we just keep
applying one to the other that'll take
all the possible combinations there and
so you get every that can be defined
recursively and you can cook up a lambda
term with arithmetic combinators that do
the recursion to define V there and
moreover the range of e on the
singletons
as a whole collection of recursively
enumerable sets this is exactly the
analog of the universal Turing machine
what I'm using is girdle numbers of
lambda expressions and so it's just like
the universal Turing machine except it's
using the mechanism of enumeration
operators and you can make finite
approximations to this by restricting a
set to being only a finite set on a
certain initial segment of the integers
there it's quite easy to see from the
definitions of application for example
that a finite operator applied to a
finite set has a finite value there
because they're only finitely many
combinations you can you need to look
through there so you stay within the
realm of finite sets but this is a kind
of space complexity here as you increase
the size of Grendel Umbra's that you're
allowed to use you get more results you
don't cancel any results you just get
more results and in the limit you get
everything that you need out of there
and in fact checking things on a finite
range is recursive so you get an
analysis of the recursion that's needed
there and you can just apply rosser's
trick to giving recursively inseparable
sets here these are I do you do a self
application and everything is fine right
here and so all of this is recursive and
so you say the zero lovers are the
things that get to the answer zero
before they ever get to the answer one
and then the disjoint set there is you
get to the answer one before you get to
the answer zero
those two disjoint sets are easily seen
to be recursively enumerable and easily
proved in the usual way that they're
inseparable I could in fact I did give a
course in the cursor function theory
this way not using Turing machines
I hope Turing will forgive me but I
thought this was a very clean way of
introducing things and you can introduce
many concepts on them now the second
part of the talk is where I do
probability or random numbers come into
the thing so here's the idea and this
idea texture cozened suggested it when
he was thinking of file programming one
simple semantics for FireWire
programming jerry Keesler thought of it
in terms of model theory because many
structures
can be thought of as being topological
and so using the topology there you say
that a random variable is just
parametrize say by the unit interval we
take a standard sample space from
probability theory a random variable is
just a parameterised family of sets of
integers such that under the topology
ohnparrot set of n the inverse image of
open sets is always measurable that's
exactly the definition we give for real
valued random variables then we use a
topological space for the reals here I'm
using the topological space of the power
set of integers and you can apply that
to lots of other structures to where a
closely associated topology is available
there on the like the powers that are in
there and so that's a really completely
standard definition and it's quite easy
to prove that the random variables form
a model for the lambda calculus of real
variables sums and products of real
variable random variables real valued
random variables sums and products of
real valued random variables are again
random variables according to the
definition because sum and product is a
continuous function and you get nice
measure theoretic properties out of the
property of continuity there of course
they're discontinuous functions that
preserve things too but plus and times
are continuous and so sums and products
have random real valued random variables
are random variables okay all the lambda
things here because of the continuity
principles here all the lambda things
mean that you can take the combinators
apply it to random variables and the
result is a random variable the random
variables are an expansion of the power
set for having families of sets and you
think of it as thinking with some
probability that you want to think of a
particular set there but you don't have
to think of a particular set you just
have to think of the whole family there
and so you have expanded the model to
random variables now for further
thinking about this and I hope there
will be time for some some sessions
where we can have a reading group or
something to go over things there it's
even better if you expand from the
classical definition of random variables
to having more logic in the thing there
by thinking of having a boolean valued
logic where the truth values are chosen
from the measurable sets measurable sets
modulo sets of measure zero that's
already fine complete boolean algebra
and so you do boolean valued logic with
the major algebra and that's the same as
introducing random variables that easy
to explain when the definitions are set
out and now what I want to do is to
think about a random algorithm here well
that reminds me it's a very good
question there's a lot of discussion
very recently on the fom list
Yanis mosque Moscow Bacchus has been
asking for a very long time what is an
algorithm you know we give the
definition of computability but that
doesn't necessarily tell you what an
algorithm is
and so I ask you to go and look at the
fom list about those things there but
I'm going to show you some algorithms
that can involve random things here now
a coin toss is just a function a
measurable function which takes heads
and tails there with probability 1/2
each or fair coin there and now if we
introduce on the power set of ends some
other Combinator's here which of course
are computable combinators I just give
the direct definitions here but you
could give lambda definitions if you
stand on your head a little bit you can
take pairs of sets of integers by taking
copies on the evens and the odds and of
course you can decode a pair that way by
looking at what happens on the evens and
what happens on the odds there so a
process of flipping coins is not just
one fair coin because if you're doing
random choices there every time you're
asked for a new choice you should take
an independent coin out of your pocket
to flip so it doesn't you don't use the
previous answer you got there over again
you get a fresh random answer out of it
so you have to have independent coins
there and it's an easy exercise in
probability theory to show that there
are infinite sequences of independent
coin fair coin choices and we can put
them together by pairing their and we
can think of pairs of pairs of pairs of
pairs as an infinite sequence of
possibilities of coin tossing there and
so I use the pairing functions there to
to represent that
now we can put that into a very
simple-minded algorithm language we just
use lambda calculus with application
lambda abstraction there with an extra
stochastic Choice thing here
it means flip a coin and then do either
M or n depending upon whether you get
heads or tails out of it and now I'm
going to give a semantics for this I
didn't try to do it here I should have
girdled numbered everything here and
think of this as a semantic as a
syntactical component here and so the
semantics here is a function on
syntactical things
integers Gretl numbers there which tells
you what the behavior of this program is
supposed to be now it depends upon an
environment for the free variables and
then I do it in terms of continuation
semantics here in other words you
evaluate a little bit of the program and
then pass the result onto the
continuation to do the rest of the
program but in the meantime you have to
keep track of your pocket of fair coins
that are so that when you're asked to
make it so stochastic choice you'll have
a coin available out of your pocket to
do it so I haven't had any way to test
this I just wrote down these equations I
think they're pretty likely to be
correct but I would really like to
discuss it more definitely here so only
go over a couple of the steps here if
you're evaluating an application that
says
find out the value of the first part
there of the operator that's supposed to
be applied and pass that on pass that on
to the continuation and then evaluate
the second term there in the environment
and pass that on to the continuation
what is a continuation supposed to do it
says oh I had to apply one to the others
who go ahead and apply that and now I'll
know what to do for the rest of the
program so that's a standard kind of
continuation passing semantics that I
think is I wrote it down correctly now
what about the probabilistic choice here
well what you do is you take the first
coin and see whether it's heads or tails
if it's heads you then evaluate the EM
and pass that value on to the
continuation if its tail's you evaluate
the other part and pass that on to the
continuation this will reduce to one or
the other of them depending on what the
first coin does in the meantime you
throw the first coin away and get ready
to use the independent coin tossing in
the future so running a closed program
means evaluating the program and the
beginning all the variables are just set
at the empty set there of course you
could have some starting values if you
wanted there and then what you do and
passing it to the continuation is you
get the final value there you throw away
the coins and that gives you the answer
gear of course while you're doing this
evaluation you've kept your pocket of
coins available there but in the very
end of course they've been used up
sufficiently so you throw them away
so I think that's a correct definition
and I think I could also prove this
thing especially if I could take more
advantage of boolean values logic the
secret is that the lebesgue major
algebra measurable sets modulo sets of
measure zero is a very symmetric major
algebra it has lots of automorphisms
that are our probability preserving
measure preserving automorphisms
any two events of the same probability
are related by an auto morphism so in
other words the problem the value of the
probability is the major thing therefore
the nature of the event I believe I can
just use standard exercises from
probability show to show any two systems
of coin tossing are related by a
automorphism of the major algebra so in
other words one pocket of coins we only
have to understand the distributions of
1/2 1/2 or the 1/2 1/2 independently
there any pocket of coins looks like any
other pocket of coins under an autumn
orphism
therefore if you use this cymatics and
get a value say that a certain program
behaves to get a certain answer with
probability greater than 0.7 if that
holds for one pocket of coins it holds
for every pocket of coins by the
automorphism argument I think you could
turn that into a proof that says though
I use specific events and specific
random variables here to implement this
D notation we hear that that autumn
orphism argument shows that the
operational running of
a program like this gives the same
answers as denotational long Boehner but
that needs to be worked out and I hope
someone will help me to work it out so
that's my cry for help here
I think the setup is good it uses only
generic ingredients generic it's good
for you right a little bit of sets a
little bit of Gretel numbering a little
bit of probability a little bit of
topology I could teach this all at an
undergraduate level junior senior level
here but of course proving some things
about it might take more effort than you
could expect to undergraduates but I
think the set up is all there and so
that we could investigate that so I hope
we will I'm going to say one more thing
here that's completely different from
this talk but if there are a few quick
questions here I'll take some questions
yes please denotational semantics very
important that it correspond to some
kind of operational semantics that we
understand and I'm wondering what the
denotational semantics you're proposing
here corresponds to in terms of an
operational picture okay I think with
probabilistic computations we have a
problem here I'm using standard
probability theory when you do on
operational semantics you use
pseudo-random number generators so what
is the connection it's precise
connection between pseudo randomness and
real randomness there's a basic question
there I think we can argue that because
the structure of the answers you know
just like the people are going back to
Rabin and the probabilistic Prime
testing there he can say oh well the the
pseudo-random number generator is so
different from the algebra that you
using for carrying out the tests there
that the random number generator
wouldn't be biased and so we can really
feel that the prime testing is sound but
I don't think that's a rigorous argument
so that's the that's the big problem
which is kind of detect the church
because you can you can test your random
choices there for bias yeah sure you
could you could set up an algorithm that
would say are these coins really really
suitable or not but of course if we want
to do really random things there then we
start with independent fair coins right
but of course other algorithms could
misbehave if they're allowed to somehow
test the coins for bias in some sense
yeah
so if I'm took this billion argued logic
perspective that you were saying I mean
is there well then see this model was
sort of it totally just a bottle of the
lambda calculus in yeah yeah sure the
the the boolean value logic we could
think in terms of set theory to
introduce boolean value sets and so
we're using the boolean value power set
with the definitions we have here any
boolean algebra complete boolean algebra
it could give you a logic there and
you'll be able to verify all the axioms
of lambda calculus there because those
are theorems that we can prove on the
basis of very elementary set theory just
needs a little properties of integers
induction and a little bit of power set
to think in terms of sets of integers
there it's just the beginning of set
theory and of course on a various topo I
think we could do the proofs
intuitionistic aliy as well it's only
based on positive information there and
negation doesn't come into it so I think
it holds intuitionistic Lee as well and
then intuitionistic topples
question okay so just give me a moment
here to step down
so this is a personal statement I want
to make my wife and I visited with
Helmut in Vienna very intensively to
visits we had there were devastated when
we heard about his death there and you
see Joseph aged 45 this is a good
picture of Helmut
his hair was always wild as far as I
remember and he forgot to shave as well
now his career was very very active and
a very special note was when he got his
PhD in Vienna
it was recovery considered so good that
the president of the country came to
give him his diploma as a special
recognition there then he had some
appointments in Darmstadt and Munich
before he had a call to come back to
Vienna where he was incredibly active in
doing things and he has many awards so
just a few of the awards that his work
gained
some of his activity is there oh yeah
and there's a picture sometimes he'll
mow did cut his hair he was one of the
organizers of the Vienna summer logic
back in 2014 but he was on all kinds of
committees and other things their
program committees both chairs as chair
and on the committee's they're endless
numbers of program committees and if you
look at the website there that they've
kept up it lists over 130 publications
so he was just amazingly active now at
the Vienna summer of logic the Austrian
magazine profile which is sort of the
Time magazine of Austria put out this
publicity here that logic is the most
important science of the world I've
copied the article for you if you read
German or get someone who reads German
to tell you I'm going to make a a
notebook with this information in it and
also the copy of the profile article
there and you can see if they justify
that statement there and there's our
picture you can see how much standing in
the picture and it says on the Cynthia
Restoration theater supporting advocates
representatives of logic and some of the
publicity they gave for themselves for
the Vienna summer of logic was it was
the largest event in the history of
logic well it was a very large
interesting meeting and has a big
turnout it was really quite quite a
success in helmet was very important in
doing the organization here's some
photographs and there are more
photographs online and I'm also have a
book of photographs from there so those
are the two chairs chair and co-chair of
it with their wives Matias Vaz and
helmet and honor there and then they
took us to the
what's the story from Museum to get our
pictures taken there and so there's
helmet with ed Clark who was a great
mentor and with whom Helmut worked there
and who is that other guy who's that
other guy in the picture
anyone recognize him so hopeless
Aristotle Aristotle yes they have a
famous copy of it of that statue so that
was great fun there oh I need to quote
something from helmet that I had here in
the profile article of course in writing
up things about logic they used
quotations from logic comics I'm sure
you know logic comics and one of the
thing that's emphasized in logic comics
is how many logicians were verifiably
insane and so they asked about that but
they gave helmet the last word the very
last paragraph of the article helmet
says about some auditions being crazy
said oh that's all ancient history the
single behavioral peculiarities which
wheel auditions show today is our
general preference for the TV series The
Big Bang Theory that was helmets joke
now I've been in contact with his wife
they were going to be here in fact I
gave him all kinds of arguments to
convince his family to come here the Sun
is high school age and that Berkeley
high would be okay to be here and so
they were all ready to come here so Anna
decided that they would go away for a
semester so they're living in Princeton
at the current time and I've been in
contact with her and she just told me
that oops she just told me oh no
there she just told me that the formal
methods and computer-aided design
conference that takes place in October
is going to have a section devoted to
helmet in his work she's coming out for
that to meet people and you can find out
about it on the website
one weekend we got noticed that three
elderly friends had passed away on
weekend of course they were elderly and
not unexpected and then the message
about helmet came through
I was sitting in the gloom of my study
feeling very very very depressed and I
thought occurred to me that I'd like to
share with you I hope I can say it
without being over emotional what I
thought was this life produces such
surprises
death removes such essentials thank you
I think we have a break or something you
know for stupor gifted students his name
oh yes I'm going to find out about it
they gave her I found they gave a place
where donations could be made to a
memorial thing so other thing too is
I've prepared a card I couldn't bring it
today so we can sign it and send it to
honor but also find out about that
scholarship fund so we can make
donations if we like to the scholarship
fund in his name I know a battle here
just planning to depart tutorial
it's
no no I
Oh
but I understand the program was a
couple of weeks past year it's like this
about ourselves the best apartment
- this have - it might be compelling